Chris Mannix is a busy man certainly
today with the NBA trade deadline the
great senior basketball writer from
Sports Illustrated his most recent
article Anthony Davis's trade demand and
the plight of the small market teams
Chris good morning thanks for joining us
what's happening Dan well I'm curious
and that's why we're having you on of
the last 24 hours
and the next you know six seven eight
hours what what has happened what could
happen well I mean they're almost to
sort of you know separate tracks one is
kind of the Anthony Davis one and you
look I have I've been writing the last
couple of days and nothing I was told
last night has changed my my take on it
that the pelicans don't want to do an
Anthony Davis deal before the deadline
they really never have there are
legitimate reasons for it you know the
the idea of getting basta involved and
their offer in the mix even if it's just
as leverage
seeing the draft play out and who gets
that number one pick and if that pick is
somehow would play just to a lot of
people inside that organization high
ranking people it never made a lot of
sense to do a deal the personal side of
it is that the pelicans some members of
the organization in the front office
anyway did they don't like how this has
all gone down they knew that at the end
of this season they were probably going
to have to find a deal for Anthony Davis
he was going to reject their long term
contract extension they knew that was
most likely and when he did that it
would effectively force them to make a
deal involving him they don't like how
this all became public and and became a
transparent attempt to get him to the
Lakers so not only do they not want to
do a deal
for the reasons I just have enumerated
they also don't want to do anything to
help out Anthony Davis and the people in
his camp okay there's two ways to look
at this you may not want to help out the
Lakers you may not like that they
embarrassed you you may not like that
Anthony Davis is ready to walk out with
a year and a half left
on his contract but the pelicans have to
make a deal that may decide if the
pelicans stay in New Orleans I mean I
feel like these small market teams as
you talked about I mean this is really
important for the future of this
franchise here is this deal with the
Lakers that they're offering everybody
is it a good deal for them no matter
what the other drama is involved no it's
it's not why eat well and for starters
if you survey the landscape and you look
at the best potential player that could
be involved in a deal
it's obviously Jason Tatum and if you
survey the landscape and you look at the
best potential draft pick package that
you can get back in return it's
obviously what Boston has because the
Celtics will not only talk to them about
their picks certainly the Memphis pick
that could be an extraordinarily
valuable pick in the next two years is
in the mix the Sacramento Kings picked
this coming year which could probably
middle of the first round is going to be
in the mix the Lakers they can only
offer their draft picks back in return
and you know Brandon Ingram is a good
player Lonzo ball is a good player
Kyle Kuzma is a good player I just don't
think and nobody I've talked to you
across the league thanks either Dan that
any of those players rises to the level
of Jason Tatum so amid that Boston deal
headlined by Jason Tatum is a
possibility why wouldn't you wait a few
months deal with a few months of
discomfort of maybe having Anthony Davis
sit out to get that deal on the table
yeah I'm with you on that that's why I
said I would I would not acquiesced to
the Lakers and you know their
desperation to make this happen by the
end of today I would wait you got time
on your hands you got Davis still under
contract just see if there's somebody
else out there who's gonna you know rise
to the occasion and you know maybe it's
New York maybe it's you know throw out
another team there but I I'm just
curious it feels like why are the Lakers
feeling desperate here
well they have very good reason to feel
that way because if you get into the
summer this summer right there isn't a
free agent out there top tier guy that
to my understanding has the Lakers
ranked as their number one destination
it could change and a lot can change in
months but you know Kawhi Leonard it
certainly feels like it's Toronto and
the Clippers Kevin Durant's you know
we've talked about this before but Kevin
Durant if he wins a championship this
year
his mindset is going to be I'm not gonna
team up with LeBron James I'm gonna
compete with him for Championships I
don't think I don't see him teaming up
with LeBron in LA Jimmy Butler's gonna
go where the money is and that's
Philadelphia
Kemba Walker is gonna go where the money
is that's either that could be somewhere
else but most likely in Charlotte so if
the Lakers go through this year they may
not get anybody this next offseason and
then you have to look at the summer 2020
and LeBron is gonna be 36 years old so
you have to start this isn't like Miami
the clock is ticking on LeBrons
productive years so not getting an three
Davis now maybe may mean they may not
get anybody of importance until the
summer of 2020 talking to Chris Mannix
the Sports Illustrated senior writer
LeBron not joining the team on the bench
now five six seats down you know it it
looks horrible but yeah you know is
there more to this or is it just a
picture I don't know enough about the
specific optics Dan but I did talk to
somebody very familiar with that
organization a couple of nights ago and
one thing he said was that the Lakers
better make this deal because it's
getting very negative out there and you
heard the the chants in the crowd in
Indiana and the message coming from this
person was that you know the the way
these young guys are seeing this is that
LeBron comes in and all this talk about
how LeBron is gonna elevate these guys
he'll do you know they'll develop
they'll become a championship team
before the all-star break the the
feeling is whether you want to think
it's it's what it's that way or not but
the feeling is that LeBron is trying to
trade them
because we know that rich ball is the
agent of LeBron James and Anthony Davis
and you know I don't think that you know
Anthony Davis runs everything by LeBron
James but I would imagine that you know
rich Paul has kept LeBron James in the
loop on all this and they have to know
it like I said the transparent attempt
to get Anthony Davis to the Lakers and
to get him there if you're just
connecting dots all the young players
got to go so you know these guys Dan
these guys are starting kind of their
own careers they're trying to make their
own mark in the NBA and the message
they're basically getting and
interpreting is that LeBron doesn't want
us here so this hasn't a chance and you
know we made some that we talked in the
preseason I use the word combustible to
describe that team we're kind of
barreling towards that that moment if
they could pass the deadline with no
deal yeah you know be great if the
players moved away from LeBron on the
bench for one game instead of the other
way around they just seceded from the
Union did want to ask you before I let
you go Kevin Durant's comments about the
article in the athletic do you think
that Golden State knows what Kevin
Durant's gonna do in the offseason no
and I've had this conversation look
today are kind of bracing for the worst
case scenario but they're gonna come out
and and recruit him you know they're
going to be aggressive in in trying to
retain him but they're they're bracing
for it they've got backup plans I mean
but the Durant stuff was just I don't I
don't really know what to make of it
half the time but what some of the
reactions Kevin has just certain things
I mean Kevin Durant has given himself a
tremendous amount of power by signing
these one-year contracts he has been
able to dictate you know what he does
certainly and he's been able to have
that power over organizations that are
over the Warriors over the last few
years
but the fallout from that is if you sign
one-year contracts you're going to have
people ask the Nano all during the
season where you're going to go next so
you can't have your cake and eat it too
if you sign short-term deals you have to
deal with it with the questions that
come with
I like the Sixers getting Tobias Harris
I really like I will I like him as a
player I know it might be short term and
Jerry West I don't know what he's doing
but you know what when the mad scientist
gets into his lab you know something
comes out of there explain that deal on
both ends do you like it I do like it on
both ends you know for the Clippers they
probably work in a resigned Tobias
Harris anyway they made him an eighty
million dollar offer this past offseason
he rejected it he's played so well that
he's going to be worth a lot more on the
open market and we know what their plan
is they're trying to open up as much cap
space as possible to get Kawhi Leonard
maybe somebody else in the offseason so
flipping a guy they work at a resign
gets them to first-round picks and
really it's three Dan because by trading
tobias it effectively guarantees they'll
miss the playoffs and they keep their
pick if it if they miss the playoffs it
won't transfer over to Boston I like the
deal from Philly's vantage point as well
but I think there's got to be another
shoe to drop I mean Tobias Harris took
16 shots a game and averaged 20 points
with the Clippers how is he going to
adjust in 20 25 games to a significantly
reduced role Schmidt Butler's had his
bumps along the way now you add to bias
Harris in the mix over the next what is
it five hours now four and a half hours
I'm really interested to see if the
Sixers deal marquel folks because teams
are called and tried to get their hands
on him and you'll have to sell low to
deal them now you're not going to get
dollar for dollar value but what you can
get back is a Terrence Ross type from
Orlando not Trevor Ariza cuz I think
they're gonna keep in Washington but a
Trevor Ariza type maybe somebody like
Ted Bazemore in Atlanta somebody off the
Phoenix Suns they can get a six seventh
or eighth man from marquel Holtz I think
that that that's being something they
strongly consider within the sixth
organization a potential bombshell today
would be what oh and I guess they
wouldn't call them bombshells if we
don't know about them but does that mean
there's there's a lot of there's a lot
of activity in Memphis right now they've
got a
you know half dozen or more offers on
the table for both Mike Conley and
Marcus all III mention Orlando because
pretty much everybody but but Jonathan
Isaac and mo Bamba is available down
there and the guys that are available
can be difference making players so I
think you can see especially in the
Eastern Conference some contenders make
moves that may not be bombshells per se
but but really upgrade them or it's
gonna be a tough playoffs thank you but
I know you got a busy day we appreciate
your time as always Chris you got a dent
that's Chris Mannix senior writer
covering the NBA for Sports Illustrated
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]